now that you've learned how to move to
capture to check and checkmate as well
as do the special moves in chess like
castling and on passant it's time for
you to feel what it's like in a real
game in a real game nobody is there to
tell you what to move you have to think
and decide what is the right move should
I move a piece or can I capture
something
should I castle or try to promote one of
my pawns this is where the thinking part
of chess comes in and you have to try
and decide what your best move is the
only way to do this is by looking at the
board and considering both your options
and your opponent's possible plans and
then trying to decide which move
improves your position the most
sometimes the right move will jump right
out at you
rook h8 checkmate and other times you'll
have absolutely no idea what the best
move is let's see if you can find a good
move in each of the following positions
black is currently up three pawns so
black decides to offer a trade of Queens
thinking will be easier to win the game
without having to deal with whites Queen
black didn't consider what the Queen was
doing on the eighth-ranked can you find
White's best move the black Queen gave
up protection of the back rank and
forgot to ask what checks White has in
the position white only has one check
but it's checkmate if you found Queen e8
checkmate
great job this checkmate is known as a
back rank checkmate in this position
after rook a1 check it looks like black
is about to deliver a back rank
checkmate what is white to do well if
white decides to block with rook e1
notice that doesn't help because after
rook takes a1 it's checkmate let's look
a little closer can you find another
white piece that can help us deal with
the check if you found the move Bishop
takes a 1 great job the bishop moves all
the way from the other side of the board
to come to the rescue
capturing the checking piece remember if
you can capture a checking piece this
can often be the
best way to get out of check in this
position what do you think is White's
best move if you're thinking rook a8
delivering a back rank checkmate you
have to remember it's not just your
moves you have to consider we also have
to figure out what is our opponent doing
in this position White's best move is
also White's only move because notice
white is in check and in this position
white must deal with the check first and
play king h1 now black has to be careful
in deal with White's thread on the next
turn
in this position can you find White's
best move notice that we can capture a
pawn with rook takes e4 but then black
is able to do the same thing with Knight
takes a 7 remember when you find a good
move always look for a better move don't
forget about your pawn on a7 it's one
move away from reaching the
eighth-ranked do you remember what
happens when a pawn reaches the other
side of the board that's right the pond
gets a promotion notice the newly
promoted Queen puts the black King into
check and threatens the knight all at
the same time after King f7 Queen takes
c6 wins the knight it takes time and
practice to find the best move now it's
your turn to continue practicing finding
the best move